hey everybody Garth Brooks here  Trisha Irwin and from our family to  yours happy holidays Merry Christmas  these two country lovebirds are in the  spirit celebrating their first ever  duets album Christmas together  out now do you always pick a an album to  play while you decorate the tree this  year it's going to be Christmas together  next year  it's going to be Christmas together and  the year after that  [Music]  I love this guy love singing with him we  have a lot of fun and we're at Disney  World I mean come on Trisha and Garth  will be at Disney World for three  holiday specials starting Thanksgiving  night on ABC  [Music]  yeah my favorite tradition that she has  is cooking then my favorite tradition of  course is eating that's my that's my  just maybe that's the secret almost 11  years of marriage or was it just meant  to be I knew at five years old that I  want to be a singer yeah at five I knew  I wanted to be Trisha here with husbands  [Music]